DEIRDRE MCINTYRE: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thanks to everyone who
has come to this talk.
So my name is Deirdre McIntyre,
and it's my great honor today
to host Dr. Kate
Granger at Google.
I actually came across
Kate's Twitter account
a couple of years ago.
And it really struck
a chord with me.
And so I've kind
of kept in contact
and tracked her over the
last couple of years.
For anyone who
doesn't know Kate,
Kate is an accomplished
doctor, writer,
and she also has an MBE,
which is pretty cool.
So on top of doing all those
things, in her spare time
she started a global campaign
to basically make sure
that being a patient
in a hospital
is a bit more kind
of a human thing.
So today, she's going to talk
to us about that campaign.
And she's going to talk
to us about her learnings
from kicking it off.
So please welcome
Dr. Kate Granger.
[APPLAUSE]
KATE GRANGER: So thank you for
that really kind introduction,
Deirdre.
Hello, my name's Kate.
The reason I'm using that
phrase will become apparent
as we go through my story.
And I'm going to tell
you a story today.
It's probably going to be
quite different from anything
you might have heard
before at a Google Talk.
So here goes.
So I'm just one girl who
had one simple idea which
brought about a global change.
And you might think, well,
how's that girl from the UK
managed that?
And I guess I need to tell
you my story to get there.
So I don't know if anyone
can spot me in this picture.
This is my graduation day
from [INAUDIBLE] University.
And I'm just there.
That's 10 and 1/2 years ago
when I graduated as a doctor.
A very proud day for me, started
my career working in the NHS,
working throughout
specialties in medicine.
And eventually,
working my way up
to becoming a consultant in
medicine for older people,
which was kind of my lifelong
professional ambition.
And a week after
that day graduating,
I got married to my lovely
husband, Chris, who's with me
today.
And we had a very
special wedding day.
And it was just
how we wanted it.
And we started our
personal lives together
as husband and wife.
Moved into a flat,
started working,
and everything seemed absolutely
perfect with our lives.
So if we fast forward a
few years, it's July, 2011.
And Chris and I have decided
that we need a holiday.
We've been working really hard.
Everything's been manic.
At work, I've been
doing all my exams.
And Chris has been
working his way
up the management
ladder at Asda, which
is the UK version of Wal-Mart.
And we thought we'd
take a holiday.
Very lucky that Chris'
auntie and uncle
live in Santa Cruz,
just down the coast.
So this is us on a
beach in Santa Cruz,
looking like we don't
have a care in the world.
We've both got good
jobs, no money worries.
We're thinking about
having a family.
And life is just idyllic.
But for the fact that I
just don't feel very well.
And I haven't felt very well
for maybe a couple of weeks
in the run-up to the trip.
But I'm being your typical
doctor and just ignoring it.
And I got off the plane and
I started with this kind
of niggling pain in my side.
And it just wouldn't go away.
And nothing was really
working to make it better.
I was just popping Paracetamol
hoping for the best
and procrastinating about it.
Well, unfortunately my symptoms
got worse and worse and worse,
until Chris took
charge of the situation
as a non-doctor in
our relationship
and decided actually it was time
to seek some medical attention.
So we ended up in the emergency
room, the Dominican Hospital
in Santa Cruz, where after
relatively little tests,
they'd found out that
I was really very sick.
My kidneys had failed.
And they did some scans to
find out the reason for that.
And unfortunately,
those scans showed
that I was riddled with cancer.
I had tumors throughout
my pelvis and my abdomen.
I had lymph nodes everywhere.
They were blocking the
tubes between my kidneys
and my bladder, which is
why my kidneys had failed.
And I was really
desperately ill.
So I got patched
up in the States.
They popped some
stents into my ureters
to get my kidneys working again.
And thankfully, that worked.
And we took the decision
that we wanted to come home.
They kind of wanted to
transfer us to Stanford
and do operations and things.
But I knew if we did that,
we'd be in the States forever.
So I just wanted to go home.
So as soon as I was well enough,
we hopped back on a flight
to the UK and started my
journey as a patient in the NHS.
I was admitted quite soon after
we got home with my presumed
ovarian cancer.
And we started what was
a disastrous journey.
Actually, it was
really catastrophic.
Everything that could
go wrong did go wrong.
So my kidneys failed again.
I ended up with
nephrostomies, which
are tubes that stick
out of your back
and drain your urine into bags.
I had to have that
done on both sides,
so I had two bags to carry
around all the time with me.
You can imagine getting
in and out of bed.
It was horrendous.
I developed a really
severe infection
on my left kidney, which
took ages to get better.
And during these first few
weeks of being a patient,
they were trying to work
out what was wrong with me.
Because they knew
from the time they
put the biopsy
under the microscope
that I didn't have
ovarian cancer.
They knew it was
something much rarer,
but they weren't sure what.
So they came back to me
with a group of tumors
that it belonged to as the
small round blue cell tumors.
And I was like,
you're joking, right?
They can't be called the
small round blue cell tumors.
That is so unimaginative.
I wanted like a proper name,
juicy name for a tumor.
But no.
And you can see lots of
small round blue cells,
I grant them that.
But it took a lot of
immunohistochemistry and fancy
cytogenetics to actually
come back with a diagnosis.
And that was given
to me four weeks
into my journey as a
desmoplastic small round cell
tumor, which is an incredibly
rare type of sarcoma.
It affects just 1 in 2 million
people, usually teenage boys.
So why it was picking
on a middle-aged woman,
I don't know.
And that was me.
It spread to my
liver and my bones.
So I was in a palliative
non-curative situation
from the outset.
We had a lot of big decisions
to make at that point about what
we did.
This tumor does respond to
chemotherapy in some cases.
And in some cases, it has
absolutely no response
to chemotherapy.
So if I had gone for treatment
and it hadn't worked,
then I could have ruined the
last few months of my life
with medical intervention.
And if I did go for
it, then I could
have got a really good outcome
and lived for a long time.
We went for chemotherapy.
It was a really
hard, long journey.
Initially, I had five cycles.
It was very tough.
I was in and out of hospital.
My bone marrow kept failing.
I kept getting really
serious infections.
I kept bleeding.
I needed multiple transfusions.
Life was really very tough.
But on New Year's Eve, 2011,
I'd been through my fifth cycle
and I was just back
in hospital after it.
And I just kind of
came to the decision
that the burden of what
I was going through
was outweighing any
benefits it was giving me.
So we kind of took
the decision together
that we were going to stop
chemotherapy at that point
because I wanted
to do one thing.
And this might sound a
bit crazy for somebody
who's got a terminal
cancer diagnosis,
but I wanted to go back to work.
I had been told I wasn't
going to work again.
And I was absolutely desperate
to prove my oncologist wrong.
So three weeks later,
after I made that decision,
I was back on the wards looking
after patients who had stroke.
And really, loving my career.
So then I was well
for 18 months,
which is really unheard
of in this tumor.
People normally get
three, six months,
that kind of time scale.
So 18 months was really
prolonged well time.
And we did loads of
things during that time.
We took lots of items
off the bucket list
and really enjoyed life.
Until September/October
time, 2013,
when things started to
progress again quite quickly.
I noticed a lump in my neck and
I was getting a lot more pain.
And then obviously,
bigger decisions
about chemotherapy,
no chemotherapy.
Knowing how tough
it was going to be,
but knowing that it could give
me lots more quality time.
So we went for
chemotherapy again.
I had four further cycles.
I had a good response.
I got 12 months more good time.
And since then, I've had two
further courses of just two
cycles each time, just
to try and keep me
well for as long as possible.
I'm just recovering from that
fourth course of chemotherapy
now.
And it's taken me a few
weeks to get back on my feet.
But obviously, I'm well
enough to come to America.
So things are all
good at the moment.
So that's my story.
During that time, I've
been through a huge amount
of health care.
I've had multiple
operations on my kidneys.
I've had radiology
interventions.
I've had so many scans
I can't count them.
I've been to loads of
primary care appointments.
oncology appointments.
I've been in lots of
different hospital wards.
And during that
time, it's given me
a lot of time to reflect
about what being a good doctor
is, what makes a good
nurse, what is care,
why does compassion
matter in health care.
And I've sat inside rooms
by myself reflecting
on these things an awful lot.
And during that time, I've
written about them as well.
And I started by writing
a couple of books,
and then I started blogging
and tweeting and sharing
my experience of health care.
Primarily, as something
to do with my time
that was productive.
But also, that I'm a really
avid medical teacher.
It's part of my role
that I do an awful lot
of medical teaching.
And me sharing my
experience is kind
of me teaching in a
funny sort of way.
And during that time, I sort
of distilled my thoughts
about care into four values.
Now, I don't know if you
have organizational values
at Google.
We have them in
our organization.
Chris has them at Asda.
But I think it's
important to have
your own personal values,
things that matter to you
as a professional.
But for me, also as a patient.
And the things that matter
to me are that people
communicate with me properly.
When communication is good,
I tend to have a good patient
experience.
And when it's not
so good, that's
when things tend to break down.
The little things
are really celebrated
and just people
take care of them.
And when I say
the little things,
I mean when somebody
comes into a hospital room
and they stand over
you, it's really
horrible and intimidating.
And somebody could just sit down
and you're on the same level.
That makes a huge
difference to me
when I'm a patient and
feeling vulnerable.
Or somebody holding your
hand when you're upset
and breaking all these
horrible news stories to me.
It's really nice
if somebody offers
that tactile reassurance.
Even somebody getting you a
drink or just those tiny acts
of kindness, they
really matter to me.
And the third thing
that matters is that I
am at the center of my care.
All too often as a patient,
you can find yourself just
somewhere out on the periphery.
And people are working really
hard to try and make you
better, but those decisions
are just whirring around
and you're not part of them.
And if anybody knew
anything about me,
it's that I'm a
slight control freak.
And that I really want to
be involved in my decisions.
And it's really
important to me that I'm
at the core of what's happening.
So person-centered
care is something
that I really aspire to when I'm
working and trying to find out
what my patients want.
And that kind of leads me
on to my fourth value, which
is about seeing me as a person.
I don't want to be seen as
that girl with the rare cancer,
or Bed Seven.
I want to be seen as Kate,
who's the doctor, who's
a wife to Chris, who is an avid
baker, who plays a flute, who's
got three nephews
and a gorgeous niece.
All these things about my life
are so much more important
than the fact I've got cancer.
And I think finding
out about those things
before you become a patient.
So finding out about the
person who's got the illness
is much more important
than focusing right
in on the condition
that people have.
So these are my stents, the
tubes that drain my kidneys.
And they're very
important to me.
They mean that I have to live my
life with those tubes sticking
out of my back,
which is horrendous.
And I can get on planes
and go to America.
And I can do all good
things, like jumping out
of airplanes and such like.
But they do need to be
replaced every so often.
And that's a small operation.
And I had that operation
done in August, 2013.
Everything went very smoothly
and I was home the same day.
Unfortunately, 36 hours later
at home, I started shivering.
And I had a fever.
And I was dragged back to
hospital kicking and screaming
by my husband.
You can kind of see
the story going.
I'm always the irrational
one when I'm unwell.
Anyway, dragged back to the
emergency room by my husband,
where we met a number of people.
We met a doctor who
was one of the doctors.
And it was really hard to
extract his name and his role,
which is important to me.
I need to know who
I'm talking to.
And then, a health care
assistant, a clinical support
worker.
I'm not sure which because
she didn't introduce herself.
Came to do my blood and
put a cannula in for me.
And then a nurse came
to put my antibiotics up
and she didn't interact
with me at all.
In fact, she was
talking to another nurse
about another patient
the whole time she
was putting my antibiotics up.
So I just felt like one
of those mannequin arms
that people practice
doing blood tests on.
You know, that's
what I felt like.
And then I met Brian.
And Brian restored
my faith somewhat.
He was a porter.
He was really nice.
He had a name.
He recognized that
I was in pain.
In fact, he was the
first person to recognize
I was in pain out of all these
health care professionals.
He got me an extra pillow
and a blanket to make sure
that I was comfortable.
And then he took extra
care pushing the trolley
over the bumps in the
corridor so that he
didn't exacerbate my pain.
And the whole time, Brian
was talking to me and Chris
just about everyday stuff.
But it really mattered
to me because I
hate being pushed
around the hospital
that I know very well
knowing that at every turn
I could bump into somebody.
Or [INAUDIBLE] that
don't recognize me
when I'm in patient role.
Or they'll have a really
awkward conversation with me,
neither of which are pleasant.
And Brian just took away
all that anxiety and phobia
about hospital, just by
being nice and attending
to those little things I
was talking about before.
And I was in hospital
for just under two weeks.
And I met lots of
people during that time.
I would say the vast majority
didn't introduce themselves.
It was an expectation that
you just put your arm out
to have your blood
pressure taken
and people would just do that
task and not kind of focus
on you being a person with an
arm who's got a blood pressure.
Or, people give me antibiotics.
I put tablets in front of me and
have very little interaction.
Now, it sounds very
strange because you're
surrounded by people all
day, but being in hospital
is actually,
really, very lonely.
Because you have your loved ones
restricted by visiting times.
So you're there and you're
having these very brief
interactions with people
that often feel meaningless.
And it can be
really very lonely.
So one evening, I was
sort of talking to Chris
about everything
that was going on.
And I was kind of
reflecting on the fact
that I thought introductions
should be present.
I thought they were
really important.
And they're the first thing
we're taught at medical school.
When you approach a
patient, you say who you
are, what you're going to do.
You ask them what they
want to be called.
And you start the
interaction that way
so that you get off
on the right footing.
And I just felt like
something had gone wrong.
In the whole process of care,
I call it passionately
reflecting,
but Chris calls it ranting.
And that evening, he
kind of inspired me
because he told me to stop
winching and do something.
So we did.
So the initial idea was to use
my already significant presence
on social media to get
a conversation going
about introductions in health
care and why they're important.
And get people just
reflecting on it.
And when people
reflect, sometimes they
change their behavior.
If you're going to do
anything on social media,
you need a catchy
hashtag, don't you?
Chris came up with
#hellomynameis
and off we went on
a strange journey
that's taken all over the
country and all over the world.
And yeah, it's been
rather exciting.
This is the first tweet I
ever sent about the campaign.
So if I step aside a little
bit and consider social media.
When you think
about social media,
I think about the
banality of it.
So you've got Justin
Bieber, haven't you?
He doesn't say anything very
useful a lot of the time
and yet he's got,
how many followers?
69.1 million followers.
So he's like one of the
most followed people.
The president's just
got involved, hasn't he?
He's just started
his Twitter account.
He's only sent 159 tweets and
has already amassed himself
5 million followers, but not
quite as many as Justin Bieber.
But people have used social
media for charity things
and for positive things as
well as the banality of it.
And I'm sure you had the ice
bucket challenge in the US.
It was certainly a
big thing in the UK,
raising money for
motor neuron disease.
And I think you
guys call it ALS.
So that was a big thing.
It raised millions of
pounds for charity.
We had the no makeup selfie
in the UK, which raised money
for Cancer Research UK.
So a lot of people took to
Twitter, including celebrities,
without their makeup and
donated money that way.
But can you actually use social
media to change behavior?
Because I guess that's what
#hellomynameis is about.
We're trying to induce a change.
I was trying to
think of things that
had used social media
in a positive way
to change behavior.
And this is a campaign
that was run in the UK
by Public Health England, trying
to get women exercising more.
So it's called This Girl Can.
And the hashtag went quite
viral over in England.
And there was an ad
campaign that went with it
and lots of social
media activity.
So it kind of brings me
back to #hellomynameis
and what we did with it.
So I decided that we needed
to give it a visual identity.
So we had got a
conversation going.
There were lots of
people tweeting about it.
My experience was
not unique, which
gave me even more motivation
to get something going.
Because there was lots
of patients saying to me,
yes, this has happened to me.
Yes, this really matters to me.
There were all sorts
of stories, like women
having babies, getting
vaginal examinations by people
they didn't know during
labor, and really
horrible things happening
to people out there
across the world.
And I was like, yeah, this
really needs to change.
We need a mind change to make
us think of patients as people
first and foremost.
And you have to think of
the person in front of you
as a person.
If you share names, you
make that connection.
It's part of how we're
brought up socially.
It's common courtesy.
So we gave it a visual
identity with a logo,
which included a smile.
Because it's not just
about saying those words.
It's about how you say them.
And a smile is an instant
anxiety reliever as a patient.
If a health care
professional smiles at you,
you instantly feel
better about whatever's
going to happen to you.
So that's why the
smile is there.
I blogged about the
campaign and invited people
to kind of pledge their support.
My clever IT geek brother
designed us a website so we
could collate
resources and things
that were happening
with the campaign.
I got it on Facebook.
Because obviously, not
everyone uses Twitter.
So I thought I'd try and get
it on another social media
channel.
So Facebook page was born.
And if you go to YouTube,
you'll find lots and lots
of videos about #hellomynameis.
Videos that have been done
trusts, videos by students,
videos across the
world actually.
There's things from Australia,
New Zealand, the US.
And I'm just going to show
you a little video now
of my own trust where I work
doing their little pledges.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
KATE GRANGER: That
video always makes
me smile because there's
some of the people
that I work with who are really
important to me professionally.
But when people
smile at you, it does
make you want to smile
back, doesn't it?
So if you have a simple idea
that takes hardly any time,
costs no money, and
improves patient experience,
then politicians want to
get involved, don't they?
So these are some of our
politicians in the UK
supporting the campaign.
So we got our prime minister.
And we're at number 10
Downing Street there.
This is our health secretary
supporting the campaign.
And then, that's the first
minister of Scotland.
But we've also got some
slightly more famous people.
Politicians might
not be that famous,
but Chris and I have met all
sorts of people on our journey
while we've been
ticking the bucket list.
And Chris meets lots
of people at his work.
And he's always there ready
with his #hellomynameis sign.
Now, you might think this is
a bit geeky or a bit gimmicky,
but I think it's a really
good way of raising
the profile of something.
And if you get people
talking about something
on social media, then
you spread a message.
And so I'm quite proud
of our little celebrity
haul, which includes
Kylie Minogue and Drew
Barrymore to include others.
But we've kind of taken
this out of social media
now, which is the
wonderful thing.
It spread right across
our health service.
We've got 112 NHS trusts onboad
supporting it, promoting it
with their staff, and
trying to get that behavior
change that we all want.
And one of the things
we've done to kind of help
push that along a bit and keep
the momentum of the campaign
going is going on tour,
which sounds kind of rock
[? chickish, ?] doesn't it?
We went on tour in June.
And we visited 16 health
care organizations.
We went 2,000 miles
and met 2,000 people.
And the reception at every place
was really, really inspiring.
And this is a clinical
commissioning group
near [INAUDIBLE] in [INAUDIBLE]
in the north of England.
There were lots of people
wanting to come and hear
my story, and using
it in their teaching
and in their own health care
practice, which was amazing.
But the beauty of
when you send a tweet
is that you don't just
reach your own country.
You reach the world.
So #hellomyname is has
caught on in other places.
We have Italian versions
of it, Spanish versions,
French versions,
German versions.
It spread right
across Australia.
In fact, one of
the people that I
used to work with who now
works in Sheffield has just
gone to Australia to do some
talks and he tweeted me to say,
Kate, it's everywhere.
I can't believe
you're so global.
And it spread right
across New Zealand.
We're working on the US.
We're getting there.
It's been slightly
slower to get going,
but I think we're
starting to get there.
But also, in places
you might not expect.
So the volunteers who
looked after patients
who were suffering with
Ebola in Sierra Leone
decided that they
wanted to support
the campaign in some way.
And one of the things
they thought about
is putting a picture
of themselves
on their protective equipment,
and then writing their names
on the helmet.
Because they've got
so many barriers
between them and their
patients, that they really
thought about it.
And I thought that
was an amazing way
of expressing the campaign.
So I thought I'd Google
#hellomynameis and see
how many results I got.
So 109,000 results.
The first, I think, 20
pages are all things
to do with my campaign.
It's very difficult to measure
these things, isn't it?
I can't go into every
health care organization
and see if these things
are happening every time.
Although, some junior
doctors are using it
as a driver for quality
improvement projects
and are doing exactly that, are
recording how many times people
introduce themselves,
promoting the campaign,
and then going back and
trying to see a change.
People have seen changes
in their patient experience
surveys after they've
introduced the campaign.
And they think a
lot of it is around
how it changes a culture.
And what I was saying about
seeing your patients as people.
So it's not just necessarily
introducing yourself.
It's that mind shift to
change how you actually
think about people.
But we can measure on
social media how much people
are talking about a topic.
So recently, we
reached our 1 billion
Twitter impression mark,
which I'm very proud of.
And it equates to
six tweets an hour.
If anyone tweets
in the audience,
but tweet away and push those
numbers up a little bit.
So as Deirdre mentioned
in her introduction,
I went to the palace in
June to receive my MBE.
And that was, obviously,
a very special day.
But the reason I went
there to get an MBE was
because my services to the NHS
and to improving care globally
and being recognised-- and
that was just completely
overwhelming and an incredibly
special day for Chris
and my parents.
And me.
So I guess I'm going to come
back to what I started with.
So one person can
have one simple idea
and make a global change.
So I thought I'd leave
you with a question.
What could you change?
I'm just a normal
girl from Yorkshire
who brought about a
change in health care,
but everyone's got that
potential within them.
So I'll leave you
with that thought.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank
you, first of all.
I think I saw a study
recently that correlated
a person's actual health with
the empathy of their caregiver.
Am I getting this right?
KATE GRANGER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So did you start that?
KATE GRANGER: I didn't,
but that study-- there's
several studies out there, that
the better the relationship you
have with your
health care provider,
the better your outcome.
And it's been repeated in
sort of surgical settings,
in cancer settings.
And I think that's why this
is so important, that we've
got to start those
relationships and consider
those relationships as
therapeutic in themselves.
That whatever the treatments
we give, or the surgeries or we
do, or whatever we do as
health care professionals,
we have to think
of the relationship
we have with our patients as
kind of the first building
block of whatever
we're going to do.
Because if you
think about it, you
are going to comply with what
your doctor recommends more
if you trust them and you
believe in what they're saying,
and you've worked together
and collaborated on whatever
the treatment plan is.
So I think that's probably
why the outcomes are
better for people who
have better relationships.
And you build
better relationships
if you're more empathic.
AUDIENCE: I know that you've
seen more hospitals in the UK
than in the US.
Did you have any impression
about whether there
was a big difference in the
culture of the hospitals
between where you were
in the US and the UK
with regard to introductions
and being patient centered?
KATE GRANGER: So
obviously, my experience
of being a patient in
the US is fairly limited.
What I noticed was that the
nurses had much more time
for you than they do in the UK.
And the doctors were kind
of a bit more distant.
So the relationship
that you have
with your nurse when you're
in inpatient in the US
seems to be really important.
That seems to be the central
thing that's going on.
And the doctors are just
kind of on the periphery
doing the orders
for the treatments,
and then the nurses are
cracking on with it.
But in the UK, we're a
little bit more collaborative
in the sense.
But I don't know about culture.
It's difficult.
From what people have said
on Twitter and things,
I think there are cultural
difficulties with building
relationships in the US.
And there is that distance, the
doctor wearing the white coat
and being the person
who is in power.
You know, in the
powerful situation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks so
much for coming and sharing
your story.
It was very inspirational.
So I think my question
is somewhat related
to the last question, which
was-- you mentioned that
even though the campaign is
slowly but surely picking up
steam here in the States.
I guess, what are
some of the barriers
that you're coming across
that-- I mean, maybe
even not barriers.
But you know, what
sort of factors
are making it slower to come
to shape here in the US?
And maybe, how can
we, as Googlers,
and how can the viewers help
sort of pick up that steam here
in the States?
KATE GRANGER: So I think
one of the barriers
that people often talk about
is "we do that already."
We don't need to be told
something so obvious
as that because we
do that already.
Now, I think if you went and
looked, videoed every health
care interaction that a
doctor has with a patient,
they wouldn't necessarily
introduce themselves
all the time.
They just think they do.
And I think that
sort of arrogance
almost is really a very
big barrier in this.
We have a campaign in
the UK called the 6 C's,
which is for nurses.
And it's like Commitment
Compassion, Courage Competence,
the things that you need
to be a really good nurse.
And that got criticised as
well for being too simplistic.
We don't need to be
told these things.
But actually, we do.
We need to go back
to the basics of care
and really sort of foster
those relationships.
And then we can worry about
all the complicated things
that come after.
So in terms of what
Googlers could do,
I think it's all about
spreading a message.
So you're in a very powerful
social media presence
in the global setting, really.
And I think anything
anybody can do
to spread this message
is really important.
We're all patients at
times in our lives.
Our children are patients.
Our elderly relatives
are patients.
And we all come into
contact with health care
during our lives.
And the experience of that has
to be better than it is now.
DEIRDRE MCINTYRE: Great.
Well, Kate, thanks again.
And I hope you enjoy the
rest of your day at Google.
KATE GRANGER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]